[Musique]
comme la plupart des sportifs de haut
niveau notre invité a eu deux vies une
avant les grandes compétitions
internationales et puis une après son
truc à lui c'était le tennis il a été
parmi les plus grands joueurs français
il a battu des pizzas et même un certain
Rogers Federer Roland Garros l'Open
d'Australie Wimbledon US Open il a joué
les plus grands tournois et il a
parfaitement connu cette pression très
solitaire du tennisman qui se bat contre
lui-même pour garder un mental d'acier à
chaque jeu perdu à chaque break à chaque
fête sa deuxième vie celle d'aujourd'hui
tourne peut-être un peu plus autour de
la notion de plaisir et de loisirs même
s'il prend sa mission très au sérieux
cette deuxième vie c'est le paddle
attention pas cette planche flottante
qui vous permet d'avancer sur l'eau à la
force de vos bras non le paddle c'est un
sport relativement nouveau qui fait
fureur en France depuis quelques années
et qu'il a pour objectif de développer
une pratique entre le tennis et le
squash vous ne connaissez pas peut-être
et bien posons lui question sur ce sujet
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenu Arnaud dit Pasqual merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui au Sénat au Dôme
Tournon vous avez directeur de Greenweez
Paris major premier directeur de la
mission paddle au sein de la Fédération
Française de Tennis par les nous un peu
de ce sport je disais assez nouveau et
que je décrivais entre le tennis et le
squash est-ce que c'est une bonne
définition c'est comme ça qu'on peut une
très bonne définition
la petite chose pour éviter la confusion
entre paddle on est bien d'accord ce que
vous avez dit et pas d'elle voilà on dit
plutôt pas d'elle dans la prononciation
pour essayer de différencier sinon c'est
vrai que dans certains dans certaines
régions dans certains territoires il y a
encore cette confusion mais c'est un
sport qui est en pleine explosion en
pleine croissance qui existe depuis de
très nombreuses années dans certains
pays l'Espagne l'Amérique du Sud
l'Argentine notamment et qui explose la
en France depuis 4-5 ans vraiment on
compte quasiment à 400 000 pratiquants
maintenant donc ça commence à faire et
moi je vais j'en parle avec passion
évidemment parce que c'est un sport très
convivial
très ludique et je trouve que c'est
assez rare d'avoir un sport dans lequel
on peut s'amuser tout de suite et ça
c'est la force de ce sport contrairement
à beaucoup d'autres sports qui demandent
un apprentissage assez long et
fastidieux parfois là on tape la balle
tout de suite même si on n'a pas
pratiqué de sport de raquette par le
passé de tennis exactement tout de suite
l'impulsion elle est donnée en fait au
départ par les joueurs de tennis parce
que ils sont dit tiens il y a un sport
de raquette sympa je vais essayer et
finalement aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y a
plus de 60% quand même des pratiquants
qui ne viennent pas du tennis donc ça ça
touche tous les horizons ça a été une
passion tout de suite je vous ai même
entendu parler d'addiction vous à ce
sujet de ce sport ouais ça addictif
complètement ouais j'ai découvert ça en
fait j'ai bossé à la Fédération
française de tennis comme directeur
technique national pendant quelques
années et en 2017 j'ai eu un peu de
temps et j'ai découvert cette cette
pratique avec un copain Arnaud Clément
un ancien joueur de tennis aussi et on a
joué deux trois fois et on est vraiment
tombé dedans et quand je dis tomber
dedans quand je dis addictif on a joué 4
5 fois par semaine pendant six mois je
pense est-ce que c'est lié aussi que au
fait que peut-être il y ait moins de
règles que ce soit un sport moins
corseté avec des règles anciennes un peu
strictes comme dans le tennis par
exemple est-ce que c'est lié à ça
probablement un petit peu il y a un côté
plus fun peut-être plus spectaculaire
même si j'ai toujours adoré le tennis et
je l'adore toujours et après limite
j'aime pas trop comparer ces deux
pratiques moi je compare le fin le
paddle quand je dis par rapport à tous
les autres sports c'est vraiment assez
simple d'accès donc il y a des
compétitions internationales de paddle
mondial ça se professionnalisme et là on
travaille sur la politique sportive donc
elle travaille sur la formation les
écoles de paddle des jeunes maintenant
qui vont commencer très tôt à s'y mettre
nous on a commencé donc il y a très peu
de temps donc on a quelques championnes
quelques champions mais qui se sont mis
à peut-être à peine une dizaine d'années
donc c'est très peu quand vous dites
nous c'est donc la France Les Français
on a un niveau moyen on vous sentez que
on est prometteur on a des filles qui
jouent très bien d'accord on a une fille
qui s'appelle Alix colombon qui est
entre 20 et 25e mondial donc qui je joue
très bien on a quelques garçons qui sont
dans le top 100 mondial mais on a encore
une fois une ou deux générations de
retard donc cet écart vous pas le
combler en quelques années donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut travailler pour
l'avenir on a besoin de défis excitant
comme cela quand on a été sportif de
haut niveau parce qu'on a connu ces
grands moments d'adrénaline extrême et
que du coup on a vraiment besoin de ce
genre de d'aventure exaltante on a
besoin de challenge je pense on a besoin
alors moi j'ai l'impression d'être
privilégié parce que j'ai une chance
folle c'est de d'avoir des passions et
j'ai eu la passion du tennis j'ai la
passion du paddle aujourd'hui ça reste
dans le sport c'est fantastique et c'est
vrai que on a on a besoin peut-être un
peu de ça pour pour s'éclater pour se
sentir vivant aussi pour avancer
mais je pense aussi que le bonheur ne
passe pas que par là quand même mais ça
y contribue forcément on parle beaucoup
en ce moment de les questions de
reconversion des sportifs de haut niveau
est-ce qu'elle a été compliquée pour
vous la reconversion ou ça s'est passé
de façon assez simple et fluide
finalement je pense qu'on est tous c'est
très singulier on est tous très
différents face à ce genre de choses
souvent on nous dit mais pourquoi vous
sentez que vous êtes en fin de carrière
pourquoi vous commencez pas déjà à vous
ouvrir à d'autres choses à commencer à
faire je crois que c'est très compliqué
quand on est engagé comme on peut l'être
dans une vitre sportif de s'intéresser à
beaucoup d'autres choses enfin
s'intéressait de mettre le pied en fait
ailleurs c'est soit on est à fond moi en
tout cas c'est comme ça que je l'ai vécu
c'est à dire que très tôt par exemple à
17 ou 18 ans je crois que j'ai appelé
mes parents pour leur dire il faut que
j'arrête les études je me lance à fond
il y a ce côté je me lance à fond tout
le temps donc je me voyais difficilement
avant d'avoir arrêté commencer autre
chose il fallait que je clôture d'accord
pour ouvrir un nouveau chapitre et ça
n'a pas rendu l'après plus difficile du
coup je savais qu'il existerait enfin
j'y étais préparé enfin c'est pas comme
si je veux dire que j'étais totalement
conscient que de toute façon une carte
de sportif c'est bref c'est court c'est
un sprint
moi ça l'a été encore plus parce que
j'ai eu des blessures
de d'enchaînement de bless
dans mon esprit c'était quand même assez
clair et en même temps j'avais je crois
cette grande excitation de l'après
autant on peut le voir enfin tout dépend
encore une fois du regard qu'on veut
porter en fait sur la vie moi c'était
qu'est-ce qui va se passer mais plutôt
en me disant c'est génial je vais avoir
plein d'autres choses à vivre une
deuxième complètement
la peur du vide j'avais pas du tout
cette crainte
comme peut-être vous l'avez vu chez des
coéquipiers ou chez des camarades non
vous n'avez pas vu si vous avez vu des
filles mais après c'est là justement
faut essayer de se dire ce qui est pas
toujours évident que malgré tout même si
on n'a pas fait d'études
c'est quand même une école de la vie qui
est quand même assez sympa où on apprend
quand même beaucoup de choses
dans le travail parce que je le disais
c'est quand même un investissement de
tous les instants c'est c'est et qu'on
demande très très tôt alors vous vous
avez arrêté l'école en première c'est ça
pour vous lancer dans une carrière de
tennis et on fait commencer les enfants
très tôt dans le tennis avec une
certaine pression de la part des parents
de l'entourage des coachs qui commencent
à arriver c'est un milieu compliqué
quand même pour les gosses ouais ça peut
l'être après tout dépend de
l'environnement moi j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance un environnement très sain ou moi
je suis Casablanca je suis du Maroc j'ai
joué très peu jusqu'à 12 ans et j'ai
fait quelques tournants en France on m'a
détecté c'est là que je suis en
transport et tu dès que tout s'est
enchaîné et j'ai toujours eu cette
impression d'être un grand privilégié en
me disant mais j'étais à la plage il y a
quelques jours encore et là je me
retrouve à jouer les championnats de
France à Roland-Garros pas pour moi
c'était complètement dingue ce qui se
passait ça l'était aussi pour ma famille
je pense que mon père
regardez ça avec beaucoup beaucoup de
recul et c'était très sympa parce que
justement cette pression dont on peut
parler qui est quand même très présent
dans le sport
moi j'ai pas eu ça au contraire c'était
vous l'observez vous en avez conscience
vous savez que c'est très présent c'est
hyper présent et c'est terrible et c'est
terrible et c'est pour ça que nous en
tant que fédération on est un peu les
garants de l'intégrité physique morale
aussi des enfants dont on s'occupe et
c'est pour ça qu'on essaie aussi
évidemment d'intégrer la famille parce
que la famille fait partie du projet
mais il faut qu'elle se tienne à la
bonne distance à la bonne place c'est
jamais évident on est une étude de 2021
qui dit qu'un enfant sur 7 et victime de
violence de maltraitance dans le monde
du sport c'est quand même un sujet
sérieux qui doit préoccuper les
instances c'est très préoccupant
évidemment il y a des déviances il y a
des débordements c'est terrible on
assiste à des choses où si on est
insiste pas on a souvent de gros doutes
et moi je me revois quelques années il y
a très longtemps sur les catégories
enfin sur les championnats jeunes que je
jouais ou en effet j'ai pu voir des
parents enfin tenir des propos mais
vraiment très dur à l'encontre de leurs
enfants moi j'ai pas vécu tout ça les
propos humiliants des propos de caisse
de celui que vous êtes aujourd'hui quel
conseil donneriez-vous au petit garçon
ou au jeune homme que vous étiez avant
qu'il ne se lance dans la vie
c'est difficile parce que
moi encore une fois je reviens sur ce
parcours j'ai vraiment le sentiment
et je l'ai toujours dit donc c'est pas
nouveau j'en parle encore avec mon père
de temps en temps j'ai toujours une
impression d'avoir beaucoup de chance et
moi c'est pas c'est pas moi que j'ai
envie de remercier en fait ceux qui
m'ont accompagné parce que la manière
dont il m'a accompagné finalement a fait
que j'ai vécu ça avec beaucoup de
sérénité et ça c'est une chance parce
que c'est un milieu qui est pas facile
parce qu'on est seul face à la défaite
souvent au tennis en dehors fait
derrière Djokovic Nadal et certain on
perd chaque semaine donc on se retrouve
quand même dans une sorte de solitude
qui est pas toujours évidente on parle
de plus en plus dans le sport aussi de
Burn Out de difficulté à psychologique à
affronter un petit peu cette vie où
c'est une remise en question permanente
forcément si le socle est solide c'est
plus facile à vivre vous disiez tout a
commencé au Maroc
Casablanca où vous êtes né vous avez
passé une belle partie de votre enfance
votre famille était installée depuis
plusieurs générations de générations je
crois c'est quoi comme souvenir pour
vous Casablanca et le fait que vous
veniez je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas
anodin comme parcours c'est assez
original un joueur français qui vient du
Maroc est-ce que ça a fait de vous un
joueur particulier est-ce que ça fait
qu'est-ce que vous apporte ça vous
apporte moi ça fait en tout cas je me
sens un peu
multiculturel je sais pas il y a quelque
chose un peu différent je me sens très
français quand je quand j'ai joué pour
le drapeau c'était quelque chose de
magique mais vraiment mais vraiment
quelque chose de très très puissant
en revanche c'est aussi c'est aussi ce
qui est génial c'est que je pense que le
fait d'avoir été du Maroc j'ai toujours
eu cette soif ensuite voyage et c'est
pour ça que cette vie m'a beaucoup plu
aussi parce qu'on voyage huit mois de
l'année quand même quand on est joueur
de tennis et il faut aimer ça faut le
vouloir et donc voilà mais après après
le Maroc ce masque ce que ça m'évoque
c'est mes débuts c'est la rencontre avec
le tennis cet amour mais inconditionnel
j'ai la première raquette je me rappelle
comme si c'était hier que j'ai reçu et
il fallait vraiment qu'on vienne me
chercher pour que j'arrête de jouer
contre le mur parce que j'avais pas le
droit de jouer encore sur les terrains
de tennis quand j'avais 7 ans donc j'en
oubliais de déjeuner enfin c'était
devenu
quelque chose de parler d'addiction on
parlait d'addiction c'était exactement
ça un jour on vous propose donc de faire
une tournée d'été en France vous
participez à six tournois dans l'été et
vous les gagnez tous donc vous faites
repérer
quel a été votre sensation est-ce que
vous avez senti vous-même que vous aviez
une capacité particulière est-ce qu'on
le sent quand on va être joueur de haut
niveau pas du tout je venais
je vais caricaturer un petit peu tout ça
mais je mangeais des steaks frites
j'avais jamais fait de footing de ma vie
et on allait à la plage tous les
week-ends
d'aller me confronter en fait au niveau
des meilleurs français je suis à des
années lumières d'imaginer que je vais
remporter ces sites tournois moi je me
disais waouh je lisais tennis de France
tennis magazine et je voyais les noms en
fait des joueurs de de mon année d'âge
et donc encore une fois c'est pour ça
moi j'ai trouvé ça complètement dingue
c'était léger en fait beaucoup de
légèreté
je découvrais moi je jouais sur terre
battue là-bas je découvre une nouvelle
surface le dur j'avais jamais joué sur
cette surface donc c'est beaucoup de
découvertes mais beaucoup de plaisir et
puis oui j'ai gagné ces temps-là et le
plus grand souvenir que j'ai sur tout
c'est qu'à l'époque c'était la mode des
Bombers c'est je suis revenu avec un
bombers au Maroc que j'ai commis parce
qu'il fait voilà c'était pas le climat
pour
très vite donc vous intégrez le
tennisétude à Poitiers très vite vous
intégrer l'INSEP l'Institut National du
Sport puis très vite les entraînements à
Roland-Garros les premiers titres en
junior l'année 97 est un festival nous
dit si je me trompe mais champion du
monde junior victoire à l'US Open junior
vous finissez l'année numéro 1 mondial
junior je passe quelques étapes mais il
y a la saison où vous passez de 572e
mondial à 80 énième mondiale en 2000
vous êtes médaille de bronze aux JO de
Sydney c'est là que vous battez Federer
je crois ce sont des années dont vous
gardez quel souvenir ce sont des débuts
fulgurants ça va très vite vous vous
dites que vous allez aller très loin où
vous êtes toujours aussi léger je pense
que je vais plus que je pense que je
vais aller très loin à ce moment là dans
ceci quand même j'ai eu cette période où
en effet l'ascension est assez
importante donc forcément c'est ce que
vous dites je suis champion du monde je
passe chez les pros tout de suite
j'explose la première année je rentre
dans l'essence ce qui va très vite
je garde les pieds sur terre je crois
mais je crois pourquoi vous croyez un
nom parce qu'on s'en rend pas compte
parce que parce que parce qu'il se passe
beaucoup de choses parce qu'il y a
les gens vous reconnaissent un petit peu
tout d'un coup parce que vous gagnez
quand même beaucoup d'argent très tôt
parce que les sponsors sont autour et
gravites il y a les agents il y a tout
ça qui est quand même très nouveau là
j'ai quitté ce petit monde
je faisais pas le dire mais c'est un peu
ça des bisounours dans des moins de 14
des moins de 16 ans et tout ça là on
rentre dans la cour des grands et on est
très attendu quand même moi je ressens
pas cette pression d'être très attendue
mais je me rends compte qu'autour de moi
ça grouille voilà ça et je me dis tiens
c'est que il se passe quelque chose et
en effet voilà je sais qu'il y a 17 ou
18 ans des des marques qui s'arrachent
pour
pour me sponsoriser et tout ça alors est
flatteur mais faut aussi s'en méfier et
là sur le moment c'est très difficile
c'est important à chaque fois le retour
mais
il y a des requins qui bien sûr
évidemment on fait en film miroiter
beaucoup de choses aux parents surtout
parce que moi à ce moment-là je suis
mineur donc c'est c'est avec les parents
que les agents en général traitent et
c'est là ouais ou c'est bien d'avoir des
gens pour vous conseiller moi mon père
était aussi avec quelques amis qui
pouvaient le conseil donc ça a été mais
oui à ce moment là je crois que je vais
aller beaucoup plus haut parce que je
gagne un tournoi ensuite ATP très
rapidement pareil l'année suivante après
les JO et je monte dans les je suis dans
les 50 premiers mondiaux et puis je me
dis j'ai 20 ans
je vois pas comment ça peut s'arrêter là
et c'est là où justement ben ça se
complique parce qu'il y a des blessures
parce que parce que c'est la tête qui
dit stop finalement
je crois qu'il y a un caractère et une
nature que j'ai de vouloir absolument
vive le moment et son trombe projeté ça
je l'ai toujours eu aussi j'ai toujours
voulu être le plus fort possible comme
quand on fait les choses à fond
mais après c'est quand même je pense
vraiment les blessures qui m'ont freiné
voilà et après c'est la tête qui est
touchait mais la tête est touchait
vraiment parce que c'est parce que c'est
c'est terrible c'est un peu
un rêve qui s'effondre quand même
je peux pas dire j'en ai été malheureux
le terme serait beaucoup trop violent
mais il y a eu quand même quelques
périodes où on regarde ce qui s'est
passé et on se dit tiens tout ça pour ça
et je vais peut-être pas pouvoir jouer
aussi longtemps que je le voudrais je
vais devoir revoir mes objectifs
peut-être à la baisse et il y a un
moment où en fait au début dans avec
cette insouciance
on croit capable de tout on peut tous
permettre et on se fixe pas de limite et
à un moment les limites elles arrivent
et on s'en rend compte et c'est là où
c'est dur en fait de prendre conscience
que finalement je serai peut-être pas
aussi fort que que je pensais pouvoir
l'être ça rend un blanc en tout cas
mais complètement exactement non non
mais c'est ça je pense que il y a
beaucoup qui voyaient en moi quand
j'avais 18 20 ans peut-être un futur
vainqueur de Grand Chelem de
Roland-Garros parce que j'étais en plus
un terrien et finalement ben non mais en
même temps c'est pas grave vous êtes
aujourd'hui justement vous faites un peu
ma transition j'ai un document à vous
proposer c'est une photo d'archives la
voici je vais expliquer pour les gens
qui nous écoutent quelle date du 5 juin
1983 c'est une photo anniversaire et
c'est la joie de Yannick Noah dans les
bras de son père après avoir remporté le
tournoi de Roland-Garros depuis Noah
aucun Français n'a gagné Roland-Garros
c'est un mythe Yannick Noah dans le
monde du tennis et pour les jeunes
joueurs c'est un mythe même un peu
encombrant c'est difficile de passer
après un jour moi je le vois pas comme
ça mais c'est un mythe complètement non
mais il fait il fait partie de
l'histoire en effet c'est le dernier
Français à avoir gagné donc un Grand
Chelem
attention il y a quand même eu des
femmes qui ont gagné des grands Chelem
mais c'est vrai que chez les hommes
c'est le dernier et en fait d'ailleurs
c'est 40 ans cette année
à prendre la suite de Yannick Noah a
gagné Roland Garros j'aimerais beaucoup
en fait mais je l'explique pas j'ai
travaillé longtemps à la Direction
technique nationale on est assez on
essaie de comprendre on essaie de savoir
il y a eu des finales mais il y a pas eu
de victoire il y a eu des finales
c'est-à-dire qu'il manque cette dernière
marche toujours alors après il y en a
beaucoup qui tirent des conclusions un
peu hâtives parce que c'est vrai qu'on
l'entend je vais pas vous cacher on
entend dire que les Français n'ont pas
assez d'ambition qu'il ne se préparent
pas assez bien qui préfèrent sortir la
veille d'un tournoi plutôt que de se
préparer très sérieusement qu'ils ne
sont pas voilà ce qu'on entend qu'ils ne
sont pas morts de faim est-ce que vous
partagez un peu ça ou c'est injuste
ingrat de dire cela
moi je crois que c'est on doit la fin
c'est je sais pas si c'est le système
qui peut permettre d'aller gravir cette
dernière marche ou si c'est quelque
chose que l'on a en soi ou si c'est
peut-être une combinaison des deux
probablement c'est-à-dire que et là je
me revois un peu formateur et je me dis
forcément nous on doit créer les
conditions de la performance mais à un
moment l'athlète vol de ses propres
ailes et c'est qu'est-ce que lui veut
vraiment qu'est-ce que lui veut
réellement je crois que ça doit venir de
lui je on peut prendre aussi l'exemple
d'enzyrodique un américain qui a été
numérique mondial qui a jamais eu besoin
de quoi que ce soit financièrement qui
avait qui arrive d'une famille très
aisée et pour autant il était mort de
faim donc je crois que c'est pas après
ça peut conditionner évidemment quand on
est un peu plus en difficulté dans
certains pays où les aides enfin voilà
ne sont pas abondantes et c'est vrai que
nous c'est donc on essaie justement de
trouver un tempérament comme celui de
Nadal Rafael Nadal ou lui on sentait
qu'il alors qu'il avait déjà multiplié
les titres il en a il en voulait encore
et ça c'est un tempérament incroyable
c'est quelque chose de dîné qu'on a pas
c'est pour ça moi je crois qu'il y a une
part d'inné de toute façon après il faut
essayer de faire grandir ça faut
l'arroser tous les jours enfin je pense
que ça peut s'éteindre il faut faire
attention hein mais mais le le le le le
la fédération est là pour ça et c'est de
former des championnats des champions je
veux dire une joueuse comme Amélie
Mauresmo a été formé à la Fédération
Française de Tennis elle a été numéro
mondiale à gagner de Grand Chelem c'est
pas rien donc ça dépend donc c'est c'est
très difficile de répondre à cette
question moi je crois qu'il y a une
grande part d'innée quand même et que la
fédé fait quand même du bon boulot mais
qu'après voilà je crois que ça doit
venir de chacun un Roland Garros en
Nadal ça vous évoque quoi
après moi ce qui me sidère ce sont ces
propos en fait c'est c'est l'humilité en
fait c'est c'est dire mais enfin je sais
pas moi quand je lis ces interviews là
et que évidemment on sent toute sa
tristesse
mais d'un autre côté c'est vous savez
les joueurs sont de passage et le
tournoi restera mais mais c'est enfin
c'est fou de dire ça alors qu'il en a
gagné 14 et que Ben nous moi en tout cas
j'aurais adoré le voir encore une fois
j'espère qu'il reviendra l'année
prochaine mais
c'est de plus en plus compromis quand
même parce qu'avec le temps qui passe
les blessures qui s'accumulent l'âge
c'est de plus en plus difficile
à gagner mais moi on aime voir les
records encore une fois battus et là
c'est vrai que ce qu'ils sont en train
parce que il est pas le seul en train
d'accomplir et complètement fou je
trouve c'est on vit la
vingt années complètement folles avec
ces trois joueurs fédéral Nadal et
Djokovic qui pour remplacer un Nadal par
exemple vous voyez quelqu'un là comme ça
au hasard
peut-être non mais voilà en fait ce qui
est marrant c'est que finalement
on se dit toujours que vous savez à
l'époque il y avait 100 traces qui avait
gagné 14 grands flammes et on se disait
mais c'est impossible ce record ne sera
jamais battu là il y en a quand même
trois qui ont pas battu le record qu'ils
l'ont explosé on peut plus il faut
arrêter maintenant de de dire que chaque
requin sera pas battu c'est c'est
absolument fou mais d'un autre côté là
Alcaraz quand on voit la manière dont il
démarre sa carrière gamme de bonne
chance qui puisse s'en rapprocher à
minima et peut-être les battre
[Musique]
j'ai des photos à vous proposer à maudit
Pasqual c'est un rituel dans cette
émission et la première que je vous
propose c'est Amélie ou desa Castéra
ministre des Sports dans ce deuxième
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron ancienne
joueuse de tennis professionnel est-ce
que ça facilite le dialogue avec les
autorités d'avoir une connaisseuse du
tennis au plus haut niveau de l'État oui
pour la Fédération ouais c'est vrai oui
bien sûr bah elle a été en plus
directrice générale il y a pas si
longtemps de la Fédération française de
tennis et connaît parfaitement le sport
c'est rouage et vous êtes pour le paddle
pour développer le paddle par exemple
quasiment une année c'était un grand
plaisir c'est vraiment une puissance
intellectuelle et c'était vraiment très
enrichissant j'ai adoré être à son
contact pendant pendant cette grosse
année et elle a mis en place aussi un
comité chargé de faire des propositions
pour assainir la situation dans les
fédérations sportives toutes les
fédérations parlent d'une crise def
fédération d'ailleurs beaucoup sont
touchés et pas seulement le tennis par
des scandales financiers sexuels
management comportement c'est une bonne
chose qu'on regarde de près ce qui s'y
passe dans la Fédération c'est plus
qu'une bonne chose c'est essentielle
aujourd'hui il y a peut-être dans
certains
certaines fédé une sorte d'omerta et il
faut que tout ça sorte mais je crois que
de manière même beaucoup plus globale
avec le tout ce qui est mis tout et tout
ça je crois que la parole se libère et
tant mieux et heureusement une deuxième
photo cette fois c'est Naomi Osaka que
vous connaissez aussi grande joueuse de
tennis japonaise qui a marqué sa
carrière par des prises de position
assez fortes soutien en mouvement Black
lives matter en 2020 puis en 2021 lors
du tournoi de Roland-Garros c'est le
refuse de participer aux conférences de
presse pour protéger sa santé mentale
dit-elle elle est allée jusqu'à se
retirer du tournoi ce qui nous amène
effectivement à parler de la santé
mentale des joueurs là aussi et des
joueuses qu'il faut protéger c'est
difficile quand on est joueur
professionnel d'être confronté au monde
médiatique qui peut être un peu cruel
parfois
oui mais je suis un peu partagé sur ce
sujet je comprends qu'on puisse mal le
vivre quand il y a une surexposition et
et tant d'attente autour de soi je peux
l'entendre mais après moi ce qui
m'embête un peu c'est ces derniers temps
c'est que on ne parle plus que de ça et
on parle plus du tout du bonheur et de
la chance de réussir dans un domaine qui
est une passion et et
je vois pas mal de reportages là dessus
évidemment que ça existe évidemment
qu'il faut en parler mais il y a pas non
plus que ça c'est les choses enfin c'est
pas blanc ou noir et je trouve qu'on
manque souvent et de plus en plus
d'ailleurs dans la vie de nuances et il
faut en remettre un petit peu mais mais
Osaka on a beaucoup souffert c'est vrai
et avec des prises de position très
fortes c'est une femme engagée et ça on
en a besoin aussi et c'est très bien
mais quand on devient personnalité
publique comme elle l'est devenue grâce
à ses titres grâce à sa place de numéro
un mondial par la force des choses en
fait on peut pas faire on peut pas faire
outre je pense que c'est c'est un
passage obligatoire alors est-ce qu'on
peut s'y préparer peut-être que il y a
peut-être dans les années de formation
du médiatringing on en parle de tout ça
mais c'est pas suffisant parce que c'est
finalement cette espèce de de foule qui
vous attend et je pense que c'est ça ce
qu'elle a mal vécu au delà des défaites
parce que encore une fois perdre je dis
pas qu'on l'accepte mais ça arrive
régulièrement mais c'est c'est ce stress
en fait de
devoir absolument réussir tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps ne pas avoir
le droit finalement à l'échec à se
sentir moins bien donc il y a forcément
une façade parce que on est athlète on
doit aussi
on parle de Poker Face peut-être on doit
montrer ou ne pas montrer justement
certaines choses à ses concurrent et
concurrentes à ses adversaires et c'est
peut-être pas tout toujours évident à
vivre mais ça dépend aussi des natures
mais il y en a de plus en plus et c'est
bien qu'on en parle parce que ça fait
partie maintenant des choses qu'il faut
aussi régler j'ai une dernière question
qui est en lien avec ce lieu on ne dit
pascol nous sommes entourés de quatre
statues qui représentent chacune une
vertu il y a ici la sagesse ici la
prudence juste ici la justice et
derrière moi l'éloquence est-ce qu'il y
a une de ses vertus qui vous parle
particulièrement qui vous caractérise
peut-être
la sagesse moi je pense que si on devait
[Musique]
poser la question mon entourage proche
ouais on a plutôt tendance à dire que
j'ai même peut-être un peu trop trop de
recul non mais sur les choses et même
sur ma carrière quand vous parliez de
toutes ces victoires moi j'ai
l'impression que ça appartient au passé
tu vois j'ai tourné la page il y en a il
y en a qui qui s'accroche toujours
toujours à leur vie passée dans le sport
ou ailleurs merci beaucoup Arnaud dis
Pascal d'avoir été avec nous dans ce bel
entretien merci d'avoir été notre invité
dans un monde à regarder merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine
émission à retrouver en replay et en
podcast bien sûr à très vite sur public
c'est ma merci
[Musique]